[Música]
porque tal con el gusto de siempre los
saludamos en su programa canadá en las
américas café que hoy podríamos llamar
también canadá en el año nuevo o el
castor renovado qué te parece
en la nueva década les damos la
bienvenida a todos ustedes dondequiera
que se encuentren y por cualquier
cualquier medio que nos estén siguiendo
porque hay gente por facebook live por
youtube live y por nuestro sitio
internet que tal cómo les va y estamos
ahora sí que tal gracias por
acompañarnos es un gusto estar con
ustedes como siempre los saluda paloma
martínez y aquí en el estudio los
escuchamos para luego més barrios como
estas pablo muy bien paloma y saludos a
los que están del otro lado de la cámara
y tenemos una nueva miembro del equipo
latinoamericano de radio canadá
internacional jessica chávez como estas
mucho visitó en tener saca muy bien
paloma mucho gusto estar aquí también y
pasarles a todo el mundo una nueva amiga
amiga miembro del equipo estamos muy
contentos de tenerla con nosotros hoy es
el primer programa el que participa así
que se echó gusto bueno
aquí estamos en nuestros estudios de
montreal como siempre hoy en el programa
les hablaremos de teatro de historias de
amor y de refugiados de bicicletas
invernales de rock and roll y cultura
punk y también de la onu que tiene una
solicitud particular para canadá con
respecto a los proyectos energéticos
proyectos de petróleo particularmente
entonces vamos a ver exactamente el
producto del oleoducto trans mount en
entonces vamos a volver con estos temas
un poquito más adelante pero como
ustedes saben no podemos pasar por alto
lo que sucedió esta semana un evento
trágico para canadá canadá está en duelo
recordemos que el miércoles un avión de
la línea de international airlines se
estrelló se estrelló en territorio iraní
viajaban en este avión 176 personas 138
de esas personas venían con dirección a
canadá y 63 eran de nacionalidad
canadiense entonces es una tragedia que
afecta muy particularmente a canadá
mucha preocupación mucha tristeza a lo
largo y ancho del territorio canadiense
durante estos días y por supuesto hay
pocas respuestas claras a lo que ha
sucedido
sabemos que canadá no tiene una
representación diplomática oficial en
irán desde hace varios años ya desde el
2012 tengo entendido y que bueno ayer
just entrado haciendo un poco referencia
a varias informaciones de la
inteligencia internacional y de agencias
de inteligencia canadiense dijo que
parecía que el avión habría sido abatido
desde el territorio iraní con un misil
pero no hay nada claro nada confirmado
todo fue dicho de manera condicional si
podemos decir así entonces lo que siento
que estamos en duelo que nada esté en
duelo exacto estamos en duelo y hay que
recordar que bueno este año comenzó con
una crisis internacional debido al
asesinato del general soleimani qasem
soleimani en general iraní que fue
asesinado en irak con un drone
estadounidense lo que provocó está
e internacional y en la región en todo
el medio oriente
irán había dicho que se que iba a haber
una réplica a ese ataque no entonces fue
ellos los que bombardearon a su vez con
cohetes dos bases militares
estadounidenses en irak y bueno es en
medio de esa confusión que llega este
accidente del avión del ucraniano
airlines que
en el que hay muchas dudas con respecto
al accidente como tú mencionabas algunas
agencias de inteligencia de
occidentales afirman que fue víctimas de
un tiro de cohete de un misil no se sabe
exactamente a ciencia cierta qué fue lo
que sucedió no hay todavía irán siguen
negando que fue algún misil de ellos sí
porque dicen que es una guerra
psicológica en todo este conflicto con
eeuu y con irán entonces no se sabe muy
bien y pues va a tope esta va a ser una
investigación muy larga que va a tomar
años y años antes de que hayan
respuestas exactamente y de hecho las
autoridades iranís esta mañana dijeron y
dirigieron el mensaje directamente a
canadá ya estados unidos dijeron si
ustedes saben que nosotros fuimos tienen
que probarlo así que donde están las
pruebas y efectivamente no hay pruebas y
como decimos la agencia las agencias de
investigación las autoridades de todos
los países implicados de boing es eeuu
de ahí y también implicados francia hay
mucha gente implicada en todo este
proceso van a tener que hacer una
investigación profunda y así es va a
tomar va a tomar mucho té y hay que
decir que ya hay investigadores de
ucrania que están en irán participando
a esa investigación y de canadá también
que fue resuelto hace poco porque irán
se negaba hasta el momento debido a esa
crisis con eeuu y como hay crisis con
eeuu entonces se mete a canadá en el
mismo lote
[Risas]
finalmente el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de canadá pues entró en
contacto con ira y finalmente pues yo
creo que ya están viajando los
investigadores canadienses ahora lo que
sabemos es que sabemos poco pero sabemos
que murió murieron 63 canadienses y
tenemos informaciones que van entrando
poco a poco pero que hacen parte de toda
la información que están de la cual
estamos seguros es que las víctimas
tenemos mucha información sobre las
víctimas y yo sí que estuviste
presentando no es un artículo sobre esto
recientemente sí exactamente porque de
las 63 víctimas canadienses hay 30 que
eran parte de la comunidad iraní de
edmonton entonces es sobre todo allá
donde se donde se siente más el choque
accidente entre esas víctimas habían
médicos habían estudiantes habían
profesores también había también una
pareja de recién casados que se fueron a
irán a llamar pues a casarse con sus
familias a celebrar su matrimonio y que
pues tristemente se encontraban en este
vuelo además de estas dos personas
también se encontraban por lo menos 15
residentes de vancouver según lo que
sabemos hasta ahora varios de montreal y
de nueva escocia también entonces en
todas estas ciudades de canadá han hecho
homenajes a las víctimas y pues como lo
dijimos un poquito más temprano todo el
mundo está preguntando qué fue lo que
pasó quieren obtener más respuestas pero
van a tomar es algo que va a tomar mucho
tiempo mucho tiempo y entendemos también
que quieran tener más información porque
no cabe duda que si alguien de tu
familia muere lo primero que quieres es
una respuesta una razón por la cual para
entender para vivir el duelo como debe
ser porque si no queda todo como perdido
en el aire pero no están identificadas
por dos víctimas pero no todas no todas
al principio salió una lista rápidamente
salió una lista nos pedían que no la
que no la presentáramos que la no
publicáramos porque había que confirmar
identidad por identidad persona por
persona entonces si radio canales y vice
han hecho un trabajo identificación de
identificación de las víctimas y ya
existe información sobre cada una de
ellas de los que son
ciudadanos canadienses entonces no hay
duda con respecto a las víctimas a los
fallecidos para identificar los otros
los de los que decíamos que eran 138 que
vendrían en dirección de canadá 63
tienen nacionalidad canadiense pero
todos los otros probablemente tenían
residencia canadiense o estaban
estudiando en canadá entonces era gente
que tenía un lazo directo con este país
y había muchos ciudadanos iraníes
también en ese vuelo no la gran mayoría
eran iraní exactamente si era gente que
estaba aprovechando las vacaciones de
inhabilidad de tiempo de fiestas para ir
a visitar a su familia
bueno pues entonces por supuesto que
enviamos nuestras condolencias a todas
esas familias y estamos pensando como
siempre en ustedes y bueno vamos a pasar
ahora a otro tema que no que no tiene
nada que ver
en esto pero que nos da mucho gusto
porque tenemos por línea skype a un
invitada especial se trata de fabio la
vaso fabiola vaso es se interesa
particularmente las políticas de género
en el mundo del rock and roll y en la
cultura punk de lima-perú ahí la tenemos
que tal fabiola cómo le va
muchas gracias por acompañarnos desde
allá desde vancouver donde usted trabaja
en el marco de la universidad de
columbia británica como investigadora
pero también como parte del instituto de
justicia social cierto de la de la
universidad como tal así es estoy
haciendo un doctorado
de género raza sexualidad justicia
social en el instituto de justicia
social
de vancouver y la contactamos un poco
como con un pretexto especial porque
vimos que había una exposición en la
galería de el departamento de historia y
de arte de la universidad de columbia
británica que aúna una exposición que
trataba justamente de la presencia del
rock y del punk de la cultura pop que en
perú estaba presentándose con fotos y
con y con información muy interesante y
nos dimos cuenta que usted estaba
relacionada con este tema y con esta
exposición en particular usted la llevó
a vancouver es una exposición de jane
green en realidad es que resultó de un
trabajo de investigación de un
investigador que se llama jane lynch la
exposición se llama situation ex y está
en la galería de arte de historia de la
universidad de vancouver de columbia
británica perdón pero usted ha hecho
mucha investigación al respecto a
justamente usted conoce este tema las
políticas de género cuéntenos de dónde
surgió esta idea porque se interesan las
políticas de género en la cultura punk y
en el rock and roll del perú como llegó
ahí
bueno yo trabajé de políticas de género
en los 90
dgs o de plano
las retomé por accidente cuando estaba
escribiendo mis libros sobre la cultura
punk en en perú conversando con los
diferentes punks y semanas de 100
entrevistas me hablaban mucho de una
punk en particular que se llamaba maría
jeta e iu pero la forma como hablaban de
ellas no era de la manera más este
empática era eran muy críticos así es
que dije bueno voy a averiguar un poco
más acerca de esta mujer
y me di cuenta de que había mucho
sexismo dentro de la escena de error
subterráneo o de punk peruana y al
escribir ese capítulo en mi libro este
es el capítulo que recibió más críticas
y más comentarios tal es así que en la
revista argumentos del instituto de
estudios peruanos sin lima me pidió que
lo revise y escribo un artículo basada
en la historia de ella que lo llame
transgrediendo a los transgresores
donde cuento cuál era el sexismo y la
misoginia que se practicaba dentro de la
escena punk peruana esa es la conexión
entre la lo que es vender politics y la
historia del punk en el perú entonces
ahora con mi siguiente proyecto y por
eso que he vuelto a la universidad es
examinar qué ha pasado la evolución de
las relaciones de género en todo el rock
peruano no solamente en este periodo de
los 80 de acuerdo y usted justamente con
esta investigación publicó un libro y
realizó como decíamos una exposición en
lima perú en el 2017
cuéntenos un poco que visualmente que
nos puede dar como imagen una exposición
y un libro de que trata sobre estos
temas en particular bueno esto fue muy
interesante porque mi intención inicial
en en diciembre de 2012 yo fui a lima a
pasar navidad y mi intención fue
voy a entrevistar unos 10-12 subtes que
son los fans peruanos y escribieron un
artículo porque se sabe muy poco sobre
la historia del punk en el perú
es esta cosa regresé a vancouver y
mantuve contacto con los papás
y cada vez llegaban más y más
testimonios así que me di cuenta aquí
tengo más de un artículo aquí tengo un
libro y mientras conversaba con ellos
también me di cuenta que muchos de ellos
habían guardado este los afiches habían
guardado los fanzines las maquetas que
son los cassettes que yo creaba
entonces yo pensé aquí también tengo
algo para hacer una exhibición entonces
me puse en comunicación con un grupo de
gente y encontré una persona que ya
había curado exhibiciones antes y nos
hicimos una alianza y dijimos bueno
hagamos una exhibición sobre rock
subterráneo y eso fue lo que se concretó
en el museo de arte contemporáneo en
febrero de 2017 algo que el museo es
este museo jamás había hecho
es la primera vez que lo que es punk
hecho en perú entró a una galería de
arte y después bueno vino vino vino el
libro después no el lingote ok al mismo
tiempo el museo se comprometió a
publicarlo en vez de salir un catálogo
solo de imágenes era el libro que es que
tiene muchísimas ilustraciones de
acuerdo tienes si tengo una pregunta
para fabiola el ponqué bueno primero que
todo me acabo de desayunar con que ponte
en perú y que la música puede estar
bastante con bastante auge por allá
notas de alguna diferencia entre el
movimiento punk en vancouver donde tú te
encuentras por ejemplo y el movimiento
pong en perú
bueno
el pan llegó tarde a perú mientras en
los países anglosajones empezó a
mediados de los setentas empezó a llegar
a los mediados de los 80s así que no
solamente llevó el pan llegó el post pan
llegó a niue digo todo
el contexto sociopolítico muy distinto y
esto es lo que lo interesante del caso
peruano porque en los 80s estábamos en
medio de un conflicto interno donde
desaparecieron o murieron más de 69.000
personas la mayoría de ellas indígenas
en la zona sur más pobre del perú al
mismo tiempo estamos pasando por una
recesión económica terrible
con la hiperinflación muy alta desempleo
una crisis social muy grande era una
sociedad muy polarizada conservadora y
en ese contexto es que sale el pan y
bueno es que se denuncian ellos esa
situación porque sabemos bueno la crisis
política en perú es conocida y denuncia
el movimiento pong teniendo en cuenta
que están en otro en ese contexto en su
en sus espectáculos en su que en sus
canciones etcétera
así es y esa es la otra cosa que es muy
interesante acerca de la escena tan
peruana y ellos no les gusta que los
llame en paz lo llama que les gusta que
ellos quieren que lo llamen subterráneo
ellos los carros de radio pero sus
letras reflejaban muy crudamente con
muchas groserías
lo que pasaba en ese momento en el perú
y me lo di
lo que es interesante si reflejaban la
violencia el conservadurismo la opresión
estatal la opresión de la familia la
opresión de la iglesia pero no les
hables de cosas de género esas no eran
cosas cerca ya porque me imagino que en
cuestiones de género
hay alguna diferencia o sea adelante es
una pregunta y alguna inferencia en
cuestiones de género entre los punks
norteamericanos o canadienses de
vancouver y los de perú
no las investigaciones de punk demuestra
de que si había mucho sexismo dentro de
la escena como como el como el rock and
roll en general con el rock en general
sin embargo el funk que abrió las
puertas para que entren más mujeres en
roles protagónicos porque una de las
características del punk
influye en todo el mundo es la ética del
hazlo tú mismo entonces uno no
necesitaba ser músico para entrar no a
tocar un día tú estabas en el en el
estrado otro día tú estabas en él
eras un miembro del público no entonces
no tenías que ser es de haber estudiado
música o nada nada de eso entonces
muchas mujeres entraron hubieron más
mujeres por ejemplo en américa latina o
más en américa del norte usted vio
alguna diferencia
y bueno hay más más bandas más que nada
y esto
estoy familiarizada con la escena
británica y si hubieron más bandas de
mujeres pero lo que es muy interesante
es que cuando se celebraron los 40 años
del pan en londres en el 2016 pero si no
me equivoco e hicieron una exhibición en
la biblioteca nacional de londres
entonces tenía un texto introductorio
ahí hablaban de las bandas típicas no
sex pistols class de than the buzzcocks
y no mencionaba en ninguna banda de
mujer de mujeres entonces que hizo la
guitarrista de la banda the slits una
banda femenina llegó y vandalizó el el
texto introductorio y puso los nombres
de las bandas de mujeres
invisibilización de la contribución
femenina o de otros géneros también al
arroz y eso es lo que también pasó en
perú que la contribución de malla zeta
invisible no siempre hablan de las
bandas de los hombres y de las mujeres
no y asia de hacia dónde va ahora su
investigación fabiola porque bueno
terminó este proyecto ya está el libro
ya fue la exposición está trayendo esta
otra exposición de su de su colega jane
green pero hacia dónde va su
investigación con respecto a estos temas
mira me interesó tanto lo que pasó con
maya teta y los comentarios acerca de
las relaciones de género dentro de la
escena de rock subterráneo los 80s que
quiero ver si habían otras maría tetas
y las cosas han cambiado porque ahora
claro si vas a un concierto vez más
mujeres
y también hay otras otras otras otros
géneros dentro y participando es más
abierto pero sin embargo en la parte en
la cuando organizan conciertos y ya han
salido mujeres de bandas a quejarse que
porque invitan más que nada a bandas de
hombres y los argumentos son los mismos
porque las mujeres no son pueden hacer
haciendo rock o no entonces hay cosas
que han cambiado si hay mayor
participación pero no se no se refleja
en mejor representación en conciertos y
en en la producción de música la viola
entonces a lo mejor hay más que un libro
no eso pero bueno fabiola vaso ha sido
un gusto conversar con usted muchas
gracias por tomarse el tiempo de
conversar con nosotros contarnos acerca
de su investigación y bueno cuando
salgan otros libros otras exposiciones
mantengan o saltando porque ya ve que
aquí todo el mundo está muy interesado
está muy interesante este tema muchas
gracias de todas maneras les aviso
muchas gracias saviola y hasta una
próxima vez entonces fabiola basso es
investigadora del instituto de justicia
social de la universidad de columbia
británica en vancouver y bueno que un
interesante sorprendente a veces son
temas que rara vez digan ponemos juntos
y decimos a ver dónde va el pont con la
con la política feministas o de género
no sé si excelente bueno ya nos da una
buena idea fabiola pues con sus estudios
y sus artículos y sus libros a venir
también sobre ese tema vamos
a ver un vídeo en el que les presentamos
nuestra aplicación para que todos
aquellos que no la hayan bajado lo hagan
y lo estamos ahora en el 2020 a que lo
haga más radio bus y lo más rápido
posible y hoy leonardo gimeno que
siempre está aquí explicando esta
aplicación está del otro lado de la no
lo podemos ver pero está del otro lado
de la ventanilla y yo lo voy a decir por
el esta aplicación la pueden encontrar
en nuestro sitio internet en radio
canadá internacional hay un un espacio
específico para bajarla y es para
bajarla en los 22 principales tiendas de
productos web que son la de apóstol y la
de android stork
que se llama google store entonces
pueden bajarla y ustedes eligen el
idioma en el que hay que la que la
pueden bajar y a partir de cualquiera de
los idiomas como el español el árabe o
el chino a partir de ahí ahí está
leonardo y sólo vemos sus sombras
[Risas]
los técnicos del otro lado de la cadena
y bueno a partir de ahí pueden encontrar
la información también en francés o en
inglés aparte de las otras lenguas
suponemos que la mayoría de nuestros
oyentes lo bajarán en español pero las
pueden bajar también tienen el mismo
programa el inglés y el francés
gustavo lucas y creo que anda por ahí y
tenemos tenemos mensajes para lo más
justamente javier gonzález no andará ahí
nos dice esperando con ansias el inicio
del programa iniciando el año con nuevos
bríos saludos cordiales de a todo el
equipo de trabajo de rc y además es
bueno gracias gracias javier y araya
para llamar mercedes mercedes dice o la
paloma y para todos si triste noticia
mis condolencias refiriéndose al
accidente de este avión
irak en irán y gustavo lucas dice saludo
desde me lo departamento de cerro largo
en uruguay feliz año 2020 para todos
saludos al pueblo canadiense y el apoyo
en estas horas difíciles después dice
gustavo lucas bienvenida a jessica
al equipo latinoamericano de radio
canadá internacional y bueno
roberts charla ivonne quien nos está
mirando en este momento bueno y
esperamos un comentario de muchas de
robert también tenemos otros mensajes
por ahí tienes un mensaje jessica de un
oyente que comenta un reportaje crea
silos marinas que comenta el reportaje
cuánto dinero asigna canadá a la lucha
contra el cambio climático los marina
que nos dice dinero no es todo en la
vida no sería mejor preguntarse cuánto
vamos a destinar este año en quitar
minas de petróleo de carbón
en países de centroamérica y de américa
del sur para ayudar al cambio climático
entonces muchas veces genera perdón
escuchas luz marina luz manera muchas
gracias los marina pablo otros aquí
tengo un mensaje de jorge óscar padilla
o para giulano se escribe con doble l
dice qué lindo marianela me gustó el
reportaje que te hicieron mucha suerte
en lo que estás emprendiendo un beso mío
de tu tía y victoria en felicitación a
quien te entrevistó
en canadá se interesen por las
costumbres de argentina y de los
argentinos
el reportaje era marianela rey y su
pasión por el tango en montreal quien
entrevistó no es la verdad louis labor
bueno y tengo para que un mensaje
también muy corto de al reportaje nuevos
fondos canadienses para continuar la
lucha contra minas antipersonal y bernal
bernard label dice son minas anti
civiles y anti mujeres y anti niños
ellos son los que te resultan atacados
heridos o asesinados no son minas
antipersonal con el nombre oficiales
minas antipersonal pero tiene razón sí y
más a menudo son justamente los niños
los que mueren con estas minas
antipersonales porque son más bajitos
son más chiquititos estas minas están
hechas no para matar pero para causar
estragos para cazar mira en colombia le
dicen quiebrapatas sin minas
quiebrapatas porque bueno tengan [ __ ] en
la pierna se la arranca y los niños como
estamos son más chiquititos entonces
desafortunadamente ellos muchas veces
mueren en esos accidentes y hay que
recordar que canadá desde hace muchos
años más de 20 o 20 más o menos que está
muy implicado en esta lucha contra las
minas antipersona porque tiene una
convención específica la convención de
oro agua
sobre las minas antipersona y continúa
como vemos en este en este artículo a
dar fondos para continuar con esta lucha
contra las minas antipersonas bueno qué
les parece porque comenzamos a seguir
leyendo también si tienen otros mensajes
por ahí yo tengo otros
gustavo locas justamente con respecto a
265 niños concebidos y abandonados por
los cascos azules de la onu en haití
gustavo nos dice en uruguay se está
investigando estos hechos pues hubo
militares uruguayos implicados en los
mismos es lamentable que ocurran estas
cosas pues desprestigian a las
instituciones y al país o se empaña el
cometido original que es el de ayudar a
mantener la paz en el lugar donde actúa
la misión un comentario de nuestro
querido amigo gustavo lucas muchas
gracias y hay otro por ahí en tu en tu
papelito que te diga
si no te doy males
ustedes pues si hay patricia jankelowitz
que prometí que comento el reportaje de
programación del mes de la herencia
hispánica en quebec bueno que dijo que
en su provincia donde vive que es en
ontario no hubo ninguna consulta ción
ningún comentario al respecto del
invento del mes de esta herencia hispana
pero bueno entonces se dice que
que también toca resaltar los la
herencia de otros grupos como de los
grupos indígenas y pues entonces también
pregunta qué fue lo que pasó que por qué
no hubo consultaciones en ontario bueno
yo creo que fue de hecho en ontario que
comenzaron las primeras por lo menos los
primeros como se diría las orillas lleva
exactamente las primeras iniciativas con
respecto del mes de la de la herencia
hispana y después como que se que se
cuestionó si era hispano o latino
americano y después el gobierno
canadiense finalmente decidió que sería
el mes de la herencia latinoamericana el
mes de septiembre y eso fue a partir
oficialmente a partir del año pasado del
2019 pero ya había algunas iniciativas
en ontario particularmente pero
consultas consultas no sean
personalmente no estoy al tanto pero
sigue sigue existiendo el mes de la
elección dos meses de la herencia
hispana y de la herencia latinos que es
el mismo mes es el mismo
octubre octubre tienes razón yo dije
septiembre pero es octubre es octubre y
lo estuvimos celebrando por primera vez
también aquí en montreal al barniz del
año pasado entonces bueno consulta tal
vez lo que hicieron fue consultar a
ciertos líderes de algunas de las de
algunas de las comunidades
latinoamericanas en canadá porque si el
parlamento canadiense decidió decir que
sí que estaba ya ha establecido como tal
es porque hubo algún tipo de pues de
intención que se vio por todo el país
probablemente así que gracias a patricia
pablo
tienes por ahí algo de los oyentes no
bueno pues el que el último que leí fue
el de nuestro amigo gustavo lucas hasta
el momento estamos a la espera de los
demás y yo tengo para que un comentario
de manuel peñafiel
el reportaje un golpe de estado dice
politóloga canadiense y le como le
responde de hecho a otro de nuestros
oyentes a la señora a otra de nuestros
oyentes claudia velasco y dice a ver es
que quisiera encontrarla dice no todo el
pueblo que esté en la calle como en
chile casi todos los expertos y
políticos están de acuerdo que
un golpe de estado evo morales no es un
dictador fue elegido cuatro veces él es
el mejor presidente que ha tenido
bolivia en toda su historia gobernó casi
14 años con el mejor resultado económico
y social que jamás haya tenido el país
antes que los presidentes o dictadores
duraban un promedio de dos años y medio
y le comenta como decíamos a claudia
velasco lo que no veo es el comentario
de claudia velasco pero probablemente
que nuestro sitio internet está toda la
línea el hilo de los comentarios de
nuestros oyentes con respecto a este
tema que llamó mucho la atención por
supuesto porque hay mucha opinión
divergente al respecto ahora si no
hablemos de nuestros reportajes de la
semana porque trabajábamos durante esta
semana en algunos de los temas hay
muchos temas pero les pedimos siempre a
los periodistas estar en el programa que
presenten uno al que quieren destacar
durante la semana voy a comenzar con
nuestra invitada en miembro del equipo
jessica que nos presenta esta semana
pues yo les presenté un reportaje sobre
las naciones unidas que insta
va a parar tres proyectos energéticos
estos tres proyectos son tres proyectos
mayores aquí en canadá
la mayoría son tienen que ver con la
provincia de columbia británica
estamos hablando de trans mount en trans
mountain es un oleoducto es la
ampliación de un oleoducto que se quiere
realizar realizar el proyecto al
principio era la iniciativa de una
empresa privada y después bueno hubieron
diferentes conflictos dos provincias la
provincia de alberta y la provincia de
columbia británica que se pelearon y
terminó el gobierno federal comprando
como tal pero entre entretanto pues hay
grupos indígenas que se oponen al
proyecto que dicen que necesitan más
consultas jon y otros grupos indígenas
que al contrario desearían investir
invertir a invertir en el proyecto e
implicarse un poco más entonces bueno a
las naciones unidas que por el momento
dicen que no hubo suficientemente una
consulta ción suficiente grande con
todos los grupos indígenas para saber
cuál es el verdadero impacto
este proyecto no solamente a los pueblos
indígenas pero también en todo lo que
tiene que ver con el medio ambiente y
también hay otro proyecto que se llama
costo del gas link
este es un oleoducto que es también en
columbia británica que es desde el
noreste hasta el noroeste y que que
quiere llevar pues el gas natural de un
lado hacia el otro y que también ahí fue
es una posición de los pueblos indígenas
porque atraviesan estos proyectos
territorios ya que son reconocidos como
territorios indígenas es totalmente
porque aunque se le llamaba tierra de la
corona sí pero ya pues ya no son más
tierras de la corona o sea no pertenecen
a canadá sino a las naciones unidas que
nación a unidad
las naciones indígenas que
tradicionalmente habitan en esos
territorios desde siempre exactamente y
la responsabilidad de si hay algún
derrame y todo eso entonces son todas
las preguntas que pues quedan como en
suspensión y a la cual se oponen varios
pueblos indígenas y cantaora naciones
unidas lo que está haciendo es decirle a
canadá tienes que frenarlos hasta que no
consultes exactamente entonces hasta que
no haya una consulta ción propia en la
cual estén involucrados todos los
pueblos indígenas que sean afectados por
esos proyectos no se puede seguir
exactamente es lo que le pide las
naciones unidas a canadá ahora lo que a
mí me queda claro es que hay una
división entre los pueblos indígenas y
los pueblos indígenas que están de
acuerdo con estos proyectos de
energéticos y otras que no necesita
naciones indígenas más organizadas que
otras hay hay naciones indígenas que se
pueden que tienen todos los recursos de
infraestructura para aprovechar de
alguna manera de los de los proyectos y
que les beneficie financieramente porque
sabemos que necesitan
un mejor nivel económico en las
comunidades indígenas y otras que no
tienen esas facilidades de
infraestructura y de y de estructuración
digamos económica y es particularmente
el caso con transmontt en donde hay
ciertos pueblos indígenas que no
absolutamente no quieren saber nada de
ese proyecto pero hay otros que al
contrario desearían comprar el proyecto
y llevar ellos al cabo toda esa
expansión y la filiar exactamente hacia
la gestión y beneficiar de todos los los
pues los laguneros económicas y el
síndrome exactamente
bueno pues muy interesante es ese
reportaje lo pueden encontrar en nuestro
sitio internet www.dgt.es reportaje de
jessica chávez de esta semana
pablo paloma tú estuviste trabajando en
un proyecto especial un proyecto sobre
teatro y amor
bueno esto es en el marco del festival
internacional de artes escénicas que se
lleva a cabo en la ciudad de vancouver
y que es desde fines de enero hasta el
16 de febrero más o menos y se presenta
en el marco de ese festival
una obra teatro musical si lo podemos
llamar así se llama el stock historia de
amor en love story
el refugi los story una historia de amor
de refugiados
es una obra digamos básicamente
preparada por tres personas ésta está
cristian barry que ese compositor está
jana moskovitz que es directora de
teatro y dramaturga y ven kaplan que es
un fundamentalmente cantante compositor
en esa obra que se llama stock que es
otra historia también entonces es hablar
de una historia de amor que sucedió que
comenzó por allá
a fines del siglo 19 y principios del
siglo 20
entonces en 1890 y 1900 y pico cuando
durante la primera guerra mundial que
hubo persecución de los judíos entre
otras y una en la historia de amor habla
justamente de una pareja que se formó
eran rumanos judíos rumanos y polonesa y
polacos digo que huyeron de la guerra y
llegaron a canadá llegaron a canarias
por separado
halifax estás escuchando el que estamos
viendo en la pantalla en este momento es
ven kaplan que es el cáncer que
interpreta la música y sus abuelos sus
bisabuelos más bien como los bisabuelos
de hanan moskovitz que llegaron más o
menos en la misma época a halifax y
estos dos estos dos personajes son jaime
y hannah se conocieron en
centro de inmigración de halifax y se
enamoraron se enamoraron y estamos en la
tercera generación en la cuarta la
cuarta porque por que hanna moskovitz es
justamente la cuarta ella es la bisnieta
exacto de jaime y jana y ella pues es
por eso que viñeta de hai mexicana
moskovitz don que es lo que cuenta esta
historia
de teatro que se presenta en back google
y lo que tú hiciste fue en tu
interesante porque combina este sonidos
con venas tela con la entrevista con
aquí en entrevista entreviste a venta
plan que ya que al músico que habla
español porque estuvo viviendo en
bolivia durante un año lo cual le
permitió aprender digamos los rudimentos
del español aunque era laborioso en la
entrevista
pero bueno salió bien entonces tenemos
el testimonio de él que es un músico
fantástico en este para hacer ese
reportaje estuve haciendo bastante
búsqueda y bueno en el reportaje se ve
que hay canciones las canciones que se
escuchan son las canciones de
interpretadas por ven acá hablan que
tiene una voz así como la de tom waits y
es muy muy interesante entonces pues me
parece que sí bueno si quieren conocer
un poco la música que se ven kaplan y la
historia de jaime y hannah y esa
historia de amor pues que vayan a
nuestro sitio
www.uned.es sea y leonardo cuando nos
habla de la feria tecnológica más grande
parece que el mundo me imagino más
grande y que presenta novedades
tecnológicas muy importantes leonardo no
está aquí para contarnos pero lo que es
cierto es que ahí podemos ver algunas de
las imágenes
la feria como tal tiene lugar en las
vegas por lo que creo
leonardo nos cuenta sobre todas las
novedades que se presentan en esta feria
que se llama ses 2020 cs 2020 y que
tiene lugar en las vegas así que el
reportaje estará disponible a partir de
mañana siempre los reportajes
tecnológicos de leonardo entra en el
sitio en los sábados por la mañana así
que www.uned.es su paloma ctu que nos
presenta y me acuerdo si sabes fabri tu
eres un perfecto ejemplo la bicicleta es
cada vez más común en el invierno y de
hecho en todas las épocas del año pero
en el invierno también y ahora resulta
que hicieron una investigación que lo
comprueba absolutamente
[Risas]
entonces parece que los canadienses son
cada vez más adeptos de la bicicleta am
en el invierno y bueno una investigación
que fue hecha por varias universidades
canadienses durante cinco años explica
cuáles son los factores que han ayudado
para que los canadienses se pongan más a
bicicletear y resulta que son buenos
una combinación de
de políticas urbanísticas de cada una de
las grandes ciudades de canadá así como
bueno preocupación por por las
cuestiones medioambientales de parte de
los ciudadanos y entre las políticas por
ejemplo para el invierno entre las
políticas que permiten que sea más fácil
andar en bicicleta es que limpian las
pistas y claves durante el invierno
entonces la gente puede circular digamos
más o menos de manera segura y porque
antes no lo hacían y había que circular
en las calles yo personalmente llevo
como tres inviernos bicicleteando pero
durante esta temporada pero no me gusta
ir por las calles porque es demasiado
peligroso a mi juicio si ven la pista
así en la vía si en la ciclovía lo hago
pues muy contento y fíjense qué bueno
entonces habido un gran aumento entre el
2 entre 1996 y el 2006 que son las
últimas cifras que analizaron en este
grupo de investigadores y yo conversé
con ryan whitney que es uno de los
geógrafos y urbanistas que estuvo
participando en la investigación
entonces ahí hay pedacitos de la
entrevista y la entrevista completa
también si la quieren
para conocer por qué los canadienses son
cada vez más adeptos del ciclismo y
antes de irnos nuestros colegas allá del
otro lado todo lo que ustedes ven y
escuchan es gracias a la gente que
estaba el otro lado de la cabina detrás
de la del vidrio detrás de la vitrina
como tal entonces quiero agradecer
particularmente a pierre-louis avenue
gioja y a leonardo gimeno por habernos
acompañado por haber hecho toda la parte
visual y auditiva de este programa así
que esto fue todo en canadá en las
américas café vamos a escuchar la
musiquita justamente que nos dice que
nos tenemos que ir tenemos en el estudio
saludo a todos y así que a chávez
saludos a todos y paloma martínez
leonardo gimeno de aquel lado que
también es parte del equipo así que
muchas gracias de nuevo nos escuchamos
nos vemos el próximo viernes chau
[Música]
y